sixers down five a little more than a
half minute to play
driving driving they're giving you the
drives
but you should at least get two points
do something well isaiah joe got a three
so now
it's a two-point game the sixers have to
foul here with a shot clock unplugged
they come up with a steal here is green
for three on the record
and b going for the miss it's still
loose who's got it it's green
lost it to embiid shot clock is
unplugged six is down to an embiid
was he fouled yes he was foul
now miami did have a foul to give
so no free throws here
coach spoelstra confirming the call but
you can check to see
when the foul was called so you could
adjust the clock accordingly
and that's certainly to the sixers
benefit they trail by two
7.1 remaining the sixers without any
time-outs here
both challenges today by both teams
proving to be an active futility
here's embiid joel embiid for the tie
got it joelle embiid coming up large
what a performance by him tonight embiid
with
34 points and we are locked at 120
as the heat burn their final timeout
[Applause]
sixers have been good out of stop
actions all night
got it right to him the direct
approach take your man off the dribble
a couple of dribbles went left squared
shoulders
excellent execution joelle converting
when his team needs it most isaiah joe
running the team or at least getting the
sixers into their offense
and b yes 36
for joelle embiid big fella looks
decisive aggressive
even on his dribbles staying nice and
low
shot clock goes down to seven
and beat again got it
[Applause]
look at the reverse pivot right here
faces him up and it just goes strong
one dribble gathers and then absorbs the
contact
[Applause]
just determined would not be denied
olynyk not enough
as he comes over to help
on an island against hiro who got it
done
tyler hero carrying the load now for the
heat
[Applause]
robinson goes to it met by embiid who's
done it all tonight
achua again stripped on the play by joe
can he come up with it he can't
other than the fact that miami will keep
it that's a great pass along the
baseline he's wide open for
two so important to defend without
fouling here keep guys like him in front
of you
help's got to come
[Applause]
danny green on tyler hero it's for three
oh and a foul again are you kidding me
at the most inopportune of times
matthias that time embiid once again
at the controls the double team they're
going to green for the record
in and out got it again and scored it
hiro took on embiid it spilled off a
couple of tips are good
by the rookie precious achua
green giving it up joe for three
green the rebound mathias for three
yes just when you need it
he hasn't been called upon often
matthias
delivering vincent hero olynyk and
robinson on the floor for miami
this is vincent that's duncan
he got fouled isaiah joe
foul duncan robinson shooting a three he
will go to the strike
with 4.8 seconds left if he makes all
three it'd be a one-point game
i can't believe he fouled him
oh he hits him there with the left hand
on on the guide hand
doc rivers so here is duncan robinson
getting two more you fouled previously
it allows the officials this room
to call this
your rebounders in there are iguodala
and vincent so up he missed it
he didn't hit the rim i thought he did
hit the underside of the rim actually
and they get to benefit from it that
experience
the sixer lead at three a three would
tie it igit allah
and that will do it